most audiences agree that jump scares
are the bane of modern horror movies too
many use them as a shortcut to frights
sacrificing mood and atmosphere for a
quick bang that does nothing but startle
like any tool in an artist arsenal
however it all comes down to execution a
well-placed jump can serve as a
satisfying payoff to slow burning
tension or it can rocket you forward
into a story with a burst of thrilling
adrenaline if you're curious about how
an often misused trope can be successful
steel your nerves because we're about to
dive headfirst into some of the best
scares that will make you jump out of
your seat what's in the boat Jaws
invented the summer blockbuster by
deftly blending charming humor
rollicking adventure and insightful
character moments all punctuated by a
few well-placed scares one of them in
particular never fails to make audiences
scream before the movie has even shown
us the shark Hooper played by Richard
Dreyfuss takes a scuba dive to
investigate an abandoned fishing boat
just as he reaches out to check a tooth
lodged in the mangled hole well
[Music]
after being unsatisfied with the scare
in test greenies spielberg reshot the
scene and editor Verna filled swimming
pool at his own expense he was
determined to get the timing just right
and all that effort was worth it
jaws still plays on big screens most
summers and you can reliably watch the
crowd ripple with shock even four
decades later wrapped her in the shed
nearly 20 years after Jaws spielberg
unleashed another adventure blockbuster
that combined action would jump out of
your skin scares while most of the parks
Dino denizens are deadly in their own
right there's one in particular that has
us terrified of maintenance sheds all
these years later throughout the movie
character speak of velociraptors in
hushed tones dr. grant is clearly
horrified to learn they're being bred in
the park and game warden Robert Muldoon
warns everyone of the danger they
present but it isn't until Ellie Sattler
played by Laura Dern ventures into a
maintenance shed that we see just why
the adult raptors are so deadly
[Music]
it's cool if you peed your pants a
little that's kind of a rite of passage
closeted corpse gore Verbinski's remake
of the Japanese movie Ringu 2002's the
ring is a quiet eerie story with no gore
or explicit violence in sight
it relies on uncanny in the dream
unsettling sounds to create an
oppressive atmosphere of dread this
makes it all the more startling when
Verbinski does sneak in one big jump
where you least expect it in a scene
that otherwise lacks any serious tension
Ruth Embry portrayed by Lindsey Frost
recounts the story of finding her
daughter's twisted corpse without
warning for Vince key cuts to I saw her
face the movie never relies on jump
scares afterward but the fear that this
early shock might be repeated serves to
enhance the tension all the way to the
haunting final frame don't you
understand Rachel
[Music]
the thing behind Winkies while
surrealist auteur David Lynch has long
been recognized as a master of the
unsettling and the uncanny
none of his films would comfortably fit
in the horror category that's what makes
it extra startling when he does go for
moments of all-out terror as he does in
the Holland Drive sitting in Winkies
diner dan and herb played by Patrick
Fischler and Michael Cooke respectively
discuss a nightmare the former had about
a man that he can see through the walls
I had a dream about this place see what
I mean okay so you had a dream about
this place what begins as a fairly
light-hearted conversation grows
increasingly unnerving as Dan compares
the dream to reality the two men walked
to the back of the diner and in typical
Incheon fashion some truly creepy stuff
ensues it's a simple enough moment but
highly effective in capturing the
surreal yet mundane logic of a nightmare
death from above Alfred Hitchcock
suspense masterpiece psycho laid the
foundation for the entire slasher film
genre but it's mainly remembered for one
particular sequence the iconic shower
scene however one psycho scene remains a
startling surprise for newcomers and
fans alike when private investigator
Milton Arbogast portrayed by Martin
balsam enters the Bates house looking
for clues Hitchcock begins establishing
attention that's vaguely unsettling
catching Arbogast glancing at each door
in hallway before he begins slowly and
carefully climbing the stairs suddenly
Arbogast stunned tumbled down the stairs
was achieved by standing balsam in front
of a rear-projection falling shot the
result feels just slightly wrong
enhancing the feeling that we too have
just been the victim of a sneak attack
The Phantom unmasked it may be tempting
to cite jump-scares as a symptom of
Hollywood running out of ideas but
they're almost as old as movies
themselves and the good ones still work
one great example of this trick comes
from universals 1925 silent production
of the Phantom of the Opera lon Cheney
was the first major icon of horror films
rising to prominence during the silent
era as the man of a thousand faces he
crafted his own makeup effects and there
was seemingly no end to the amount of
discomfort he was willing to put himself
through to spook his fans for phantom he
devised an elaborate construction of
wires and paint that gave him an
alarmingly school-like face Cheney's
creepy mug is first revealed when
Christine played by Mary Philbin slowly
works up the courage to pull off his
mask stories have viewers fainting in
the theater at the film's premiere
quickly became something of a Hollywood
legend
how much Universal may have played up
these reports and advertising remains
difficult to say but it's undeniable
that the shock remains effective even 90
years later thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you